it's finally here you guys game of
thrones premiered back in the spring of
2011 and now after eight years 23 if
you're a fan of the books we are finally
getting the answer we've all been
waiting for
who will win cleganebowl it's a battle
of the Titans in one corner we've got a
man who can crush your head like a
gusher and in the other we've got a man
who really likes his chickens it's the
meme the writers have reluctantly
included for fanservice but nevertheless
good boy
oh and I guess we'll also get to find
out who gets to rule Westeros so that's
cool
hello Internet welcome to film Theory
the show where the night is dark and
full of theories you guys I can't
believe that Game of Thrones is nearly
over I know I know that we're gonna get
ourselves a variety of spin-offs and
whatnot but we can never go back to this
time when we were first discovering a
fantasy series that was as rich as Lord
of the Rings with the added bonus
anxiety of thinking that any character
could die at any time and at this point
with only six episodes left it's
impressive that Game of Thrones still
feels like it could go in any Dozen of
different directions well John and Danny
save the world and become Westeros as
hot young power couple will bran turn
out to be the night king or will Podrick
heal the world with his magical
lovemaking these ladies enjoyed him so
much they gave him the time for free
no one knows well no one except for
Sansa's friends it is probably the
single most hyped series finale in TV
history since Breaking Bad ended back in
so much so that there are betting odds
for who will rule Westeros at the end as
well as who will be first to die in this
new season let's just say looking at the
odds things aren't looking too hot for
the Greyjoy's and so of course true to
form
today's theory is all about how this
whole thing is gonna end now is my
theory today gonna tell you to run to
Vegas plunk down your cash on Tyrion
Very's and Danny for the wind play show
to get yourself rich no today's theory
is about how Game of Thrones should end
not about how it will end
and I think that those are two very
different things at this point the
narrative of Game
roans is constrained by a number of
factors it's a victim of its own success
I mean sure Game of Thrones isn't afraid
of being dark and ripping fans hearts
out but HBO might now be reluctant to do
certain things now that they want people
to stay invested in Game of Thrones
spin-off shows they might feel like they
need a more TV friendly ending that
leaves people wanting more or leave
certain characters alive plus who knows
how much the end of the series will line
up with the way that george RR martin
decides to end the books I mean if
you're Martin don't you kinda want the
show to end a bit differently so that
there's still some reason to read those
last two books winds of winter and a
dream of spring when they eventually
come out if they eventually come out
they're never coming out are they so
today I'm talking about the ending that
should happen once you get past all the
dragons and war and incest what is Game
of Thrones really about and what kind of
ending would serve all those themes the
best it may not be the ending that
Westeros needs but it is the ending that
Westeros deserves as Kate says in her
prophecy for Daenerys to go forward you
must go back so to think about how Game
of Thrones should end let's take a look
at how it begins the pilot of a show
like Game of Thrones is important
because it's likely to establish not
just the characters and setting and plot
points that will endure throughout the
show but also because they tend to hint
at the themes and messages that the show
will explore throughout the rest of its
run in our inaugural episode we
establish three main houses Stark
Lannister and Targaryen these are the
ones that the show tells us to invest in
at the outset and while plenty of other
houses have become important over the
course of the series the show going into
its final season is still focused on
these three the Tyrells are dead
Holton's are dead the Martel's are dead
those who die here in this newly and
watch the phrase are dead
when takane vows free the Greyjoy's and
Tully's are still kicking around but be
honest with me do you really care
no every time I hear about the Greyjoy's
my eyes roll into the back of my head
she's dead may never die what is dead
may never die more like what is dead
should stay dead and just stick on their
own damn Island
their distractions they were never real
contenders for the throne but not only
are the Starks Lannister's and Targaryen
z-- the first three houses we become
familiar with each one demonstrates a
major theme that ends up pervading the
rest of the series 1 the price of power
to the failure of man's institutions and
3 the dangers of pride and by looking at
the way the series explores these themes
and these houses we get ourselves a
clear pathway to what should be the
ending for the entire series theme
number 1 the price of power from the
earliest days of watching the series we
may not have been able to tell a maester
pycelle from a Barristan Selmy but one
thing we all knew was the Lannister
motto
elana so old we don't say it was beaten
over our head with a seemingly limitless
amount of money they bobbed their way
into power and prestige in Westeros they
understand the cost of things and they
understood that sometimes that
most is more than just a bag of gold
we're often than not the price of their
own lofty ambitions was human life in
the pilot alone they poison the hand of
the king Jon Arryn to prevent him from
revealing the fact that Robert's
children were in fact Jamie's and then
they attempt to murder bran for
discovering the same exact thing whether
they're pushing children from Windows
hijacking their enemies weddings are
blowing up hundreds of people to avoid
going to trial there is nothing that the
Lannisters won't do to remain in charge
and while the juicy violence is
certainly a part of the reason why we
watched the show a huge part of the
narrative is all about the debts that
need to be paid when you take these
sorts of actions the Karma that results
from this kind of lust for power Tywin
Lannister masterminds the red wedding
which kills Catelyn Stark
only to have Petyr Baelish reciprocate
by killing his grandson during the
purple wedding Cersei may solve one
problem employing of the Sept of Baelor
at the end of season six but the karmic
retribution she receives is that her
last living child Tom and jumps to his
death out of greed she achieves power
but at the cost of the only thing that
truly mattered to her in her life her
children dying off the Lannisters do
indeed pay their debts and while it's
most obvious with the Lannisters the
price of power is something that
pervades every element of the series
Stannis is so consumed by his desire to
be king that he's willing to murder his
brother Renly and burn his daughter
Shireen he still loses and dies Daenerys
his older brother of a series arranges
to have his sister married off to a
bloodthirsty warlord just so he can
retake the crown and in the end the
series gets his crown is not the way he
intended even the more honourable quests
for power come with a huge price tag few
would argue that Jon Snow didn't hold
the moral high ground against Ramsay
Bolton during the Battle of the bastards
but the show makes sure that we see that
even justified conquest is awful Jon
Snow doesn't want thousands of people to
die offering Ramsay a one-on-one duel
instead but when Ramsay refuses everyone
on that battlefield ends up dying anyway
so much so that John almost suffocates
to death under a giant pile of corpse
and then got Daenerys who genuinely has
progressive ideas about abolishing
slavery and demolishing class divisions
but for someone who talks about leaving
the world a better place than she found
it she sure does love burning people
alive the moral here is that everyone
good bad or otherwise has blood on their
hands and shirt while you may be
rewarded temporarily eventually you're
gonna have to pay your karmic debt theme
number two the failure of institutions
the thirst for power is a big element to
Game of Thrones to be sure but in
reality it's just a symptom of
institutions that humans have put into
place for themselves part of the reason
Daenerys wants to break the wheel in the
first place is because the rules about
how people are governed are unjust and
lead to abuse the system of royal
succession for example not only leads to
infighting but also gives rise to rulers
who have no business ruling Joffrey
cared more about torturing people with
crossbows than he did about ruling
Tommen he was around 13 when he took the
throne heck even King Baratheon I mean
sure he was older and not a homicidal
sociopath but he readily admits that he
was a warrior rather than a ruler the
fight between Stannis and Renly sure
Stannis had a better claim to the throne
as the next oldest brother to the king
but Renly was probably the better option
having more public support and
leadership ability the systems devised
by men are constantly failing the
characters know that they're flawed but
they don't do anything to fundamentally
change the system even Daenerys herself
is a part of this problem I mean think
about it she says that she wants to
change everything but at the same time
she insists that she's the rightful
claimed as a throne simply because she's
the daughter of a former king a former
king who happened to be a homicidal
maniac she says she wants to break the
wheel but apparently she doesn't want to
break the wheel entirely she wants to
keep intact the parts of the wheel that
you know support her claim to the throne
I mean nobody is really advocating for
democracy in Westeros so how much are we
really shattering them
friends and it's not just political
systems either look at another
institution that plays a huge role
throughout the story marriage tenaris at
least in the books as a
thirteen-year-old who's married off to a
warlord
Sansa's marriage to Tyrion is loveless
and fails to protect her her marriage to
Ramsay is even worse
neither Robert Baratheon nor Cersei is
happy in their marriage even Catelyn and
Eddard Stark what should be a loving
marriage between two of the show's most
noble characters is tainted by her
mistaken belief that he cheated on her
leading to the birth of Jon Snow and her
lifelong resentment of him the only
truly positive love-filled marriage that
we see on screen is with Robb Stark and
that didn't turn out too well either
so if government and marriage aren't
working too well in Westeros then how
about religion no again according to
Georgie mark sure the Lord of Light may
be able to raise people from the dead
and give birth to shadow babies he also
requires human sacrifices in exchange
for winning battles that whoops you end
up losing anyway
then there's the entirety of seasons
five and six when Tom and yields too
much power to the high Sparrow it is one
of the longest in my opinion most
frustrating plot lines in the series
because it feels like filler that just
slogs on for way too long but when you
actually stop and look at the detail of
the entire story of Game of Thrones the
purpose actually becomes clear it's to
show that no one no instant
[ __ ] is good no matter how pious or
noble the intentions might at first seem
which is exactly why the Starks are so
important the story Eddard Stark was man
defined by his belief of the inherent
good of human institutions and it gets
him his reliance on the arbitrary rules
and the way things are supposed to be
done it's empty editor Samsa desires
alight the finery living with the nobles
at King's Landing
oh and she finally did said she winds up
being abused by Joffrey and then the
bull it's only when she rejects
society's rules for her that she regains
any sort of power in the story
Jon Snow is constantly trying to help
the Nights Watch help themselves
and their response is to kill him for it
now when the aftermath of the Battle of
hardhome where the tribe leaders pledged
their weapons to him he's basically the
equivalent of the king-beyond-the-wall
he is a wildling and is more successful
now than he ever was when he was wearing
the black but perhaps the most obvious
example is Arya the beginning of the
story
Arya admires her sword master Syrio
Forel a water dancer with perfect
stances and elegant mousse found quickly
disabused as her
we'll talk to that strike the greatest
swordsman who ever lived
[Music]
your friends dead
not restaurants Adama and a big
she then moves on to overturn the
organization of the faceless men to
become a merciless assassin following
her own rules and taking on any identity
she chooses and in the process she
literally has to reject her identity as
a start it's only when the Starks deny
their name and their upbringing their
houses belief on the safety of
institutions that they're finally able
to survive in this world looking across
the series all the systems are unjust
unfair and destructive human society
fails over and again which leads us to
theme number three the dangers of pride
potential threats to our beloved
characters are telegraphed everywhere in
this show Catelyn actively warns Robb
Stark to stay true to his marriage
promise - the phrase Walder Frey is a
dangerous man to cross I know that you
gave him your word treat your oaths
recklessly and your people will do the
same and he doesn't and winds up dead
when Eddard threatens to expose Circe's
adultery she turns the threat right back
at him when the King returns from his
hunt I'm telling the truth wherever you
go Roberts wrath will follow you and
what of my wrath let's talk when you
play the game of Thrones you win you die
he's arrested and executed the slave
masters of murine are given a pretty
sweet deal by Tyrion to take seven years
to phase out slavery but they're
unwilling to cooperate and say it with
me now they get themselves killed in all
of these cases and so many more
throughout the series Clyde is the
reason for their downfall Robb and Ned
and the slave masters were so confident
that they were untouchable that they
ignored the warnings when Jon Snow
returned to Castle black from his
semester abroad with the wildlings he
gives the Nights Watch the advice to let
the wildlings through they refused and
most died as a result
think of wildlings let's not forget
Mance Rayder the king-beyond-the-wall
their unofficial ruler a man who refuses
to bend his knee to anyone else that
pride costs him his life the lives of
many of his followers Mance Rayder was
brave
Travon I've never been how many of us
people died pride pride gets people
killed it gets them to not cooperate it
gets them to not listen to each other it
gets them to ignore the warning signs
and by the time they realize the danger
it's too late to do anything about it
nowhere is this better exemplified than
the last of our three houses the
targaryen the series this time on the
show was short-lived but it was filled
with misplaced pride the next time you
raise a hand to me will be the last time
you have hands and the would-be Dragon
King ignores the warnings and earns
himself his long overdue golden crown
danny is equally prideful though and
pays for it dearly on multiple occasions
it's actually the entire point of
another of my less than favorite plot
lines marine in Mereen she struggles
against her pride constantly as she
tries to rule over slavers Bay on one
hand her treatment of the Masters wins
her no favors I've ordered Daario to
execute every master in yunkai loading
the Masters into pens and slaughtering
them by the thousands is also treating
men like beasts there's a good and evil
on both sides in every war slavery is
real I will end those behind it but at
the same time she loses the popular vote
when she decides to publicly execute her
advisor and of course there's the
fighting pits
despite being advised by others to
uphold this ancient tradition for the
good of people she thinks she knows
better refuses to heed the concerns of
her team and opens the door to more
animosity between her and the city they
did ask for some concessions concessions
politics is the art of compromise your
grace I'm not a politician I'm queen
it's easier to rule happy subjects than
angry ones in each case a prideful
decision from her comes with heavy
negative consequences and now as we race
towards the finish of the show pride is
once again a huge focus around her
storylines demanding that Jon Snow kneel
to her as Queen before she'll lend him
any favor I will fight for you when he
bend the knee
my people won't accept a southern ruler
it shows you to leap them isn't their
survival more important than your pride
here's why all this matters throughout
the entirety of the series everyone has
ignored the real threat Westeros the
White Walkers remember how I said that
pilot episodes tend to kick off all your
important characters and themes well in
the opening minutes of the show what are
we shown not any of the houses not
King's Landing heck not even characters
that live through the opening moments no
we are shown the danger of the White
Walkers as they butcher a scouting party
even before that iconic theme music
plays for the first time it is the White
Walkers that are getting top billing
later on that same episode we see Ned
make his first crucial decision of
series and by extension his first
crucial mistake of the series he has to
choose what to do with the deserter who
escaped the white Walker attack with his
life
Ned being a man of rules and
institutions decides to behead him
despite the boys warnings of the white
Walker threat not mine so I saw white
walkers and from that point forward
everyone just ignores the iced zombie
threat shortly after Eddard's beheaded
Alistair thorn has sent to King's
Landing with a zombie hand to show off
and no one cares
the Nights Watch meanwhile is sending
out dozens of messages to all the houses
asking for help and all of the messages
get ignored for months Samwell Tarly
tells the maesters in The Citadel that
he has actually seen these things and
that the threat is real and they choose
to just sit on their hands winter was
coming and coming and still coming and
took a really long time to get there but
no one cared no one prepared
they fought petty little battles against
each other sacrificing thousands of
lives just to decide who got to sit on a
really uncomfortable looking chair and
now the karmic debt is coming due in the
final hours Cersei sees an undead white
point blank and her pride prevents her
from partnering with rivals to the
throne in return the king in the north
would extend this truce you will remain
in the north where he belongs I cannot
give you what you ask I cannot serve two
Queens
then there is nothing left
disgust so dad will come North first
enjoy dealing with them we will deal
with whatever is left of you
if this show has taught us anything it's
that everyone tends to die when people
don't cooperate so what kind of ending
best fits with what Game of Thrones is
trying to tell us how should Game of
Thrones end well if we're looking at it
from a purely thematic standpoint the
White Walkers should wipe out everyone
mankind hasn't learned it's lesson we
either work together to all survive
where we all end up dying people
continue to be disloyal brutal willfully
ignorant they rely on systems that lead
to abuse they're prideful and that pride
prevents them from working together so
who deserves to rule Westeros no one
I mean Jared Danny and John are working
together now but it's a little too
little too late they're all too
self-interested too short-sighted to
ethically compromised the ending that
makes the most romantic sense for Game
of Thrones is for the White Walkers to
win for society to reset in some way
it's not that mankind should lose
because Game of Thrones is some
nihilistic universe in which choices
don't matter it's the complete opposite
it's that the choices mankind made in
the lead-up to winter or wrong they made
the wrong choices they weren't the
responsible ones and in the end those
choices should lead to their ultimate
downfall and if you don't believe that
this is the ending that's deserved
remember it's mankind's fault that the
White Walkers exist in the first place
in the season 4 finale episode the
children grand Lord that the White
Walkers were created by the children of
the forest thousands of years ago but
the reason they created them was to
defend against the destructive force
that was invading Westeros
the first men men landed in Westeros and
immediately began slaughtering the
indigenous races in this way the fall of
Westeros is as much karma as it is
anything else
there would be a karmic debt to pay for
mankind's brutality for their unjust
systems to be wiped out for their
inability to cooperate leading to their
demise at the hands of a unified
singular white Walker force that
wouldn't exist if it wasn't for them one
that the show's creators decided to show
us before we met any other characters in
the series what makes the most sense is
for winter to come for all mankind will
my prediction come true
oh it's hard to spin off a series when
everyone's dead so probably not but you
gotta admit that would be one really
memorable way to end a series but hey
that's just a theory Oh film theory
[Music]
you